[Music]
hello
listener you are on a bonus overdose of
the plastic pills podcast where we are
back
today on deliz and today's a treat
because i have with me an
og deliz scholar and translator
and charles staval most of the people on
this or most of my listeners and viewers
happen to be younger than me
and i'm not even very old that's why
we're joined by
charles today who is with all due
respect
old and has been reading and writing and
translating delis since before most of
us
were born so if you've read a lot of
delays you may already know
unbeknownst or notes to you charles
books
gilda liz abc's and gio de liz
a key concepts he also works with daniel
w
smith who is one of if not the top
anglophone deluge scholars and
commentators in the world
um and charles i didn't know this until
i just checked but you also translated
the new edition of delizza's
logic of sense yes that indeed
that was uh that's a new actually that's
an updated translation from
the 1990 translation most people don't
know that it just sort of
slipped out there onto the market but we
did a complete review
uh constantine bundes and i did a
complete review of the original
translation
so one made sure that we got our
crossed all our t's and dotted our eyes
for a change because the first one had
some mistakes
well that's disheartening because i only
have the first one i didn't know that
the second one existed until they're not
they're not huge don't worry you won't
you won't go go wrong but it's just it's
nice to get things
translated right all right so you're
hearing the voice of course of
charles stevall um until recently
professor of french studies at wayne
state is that right
correct um and all this to say
if you're here you're riding the delu's
hype train
and there's a treat for you so uh
charles thanks so much for being here
thank you um first questions first
being the og de la scholar in the room
can you take us back to the beginning
maybe give us a picture of the academic
climate when you were a grad student and
after
and perhaps why deluse studies became a
research project that you wanted to
spend
now so much time on yeah sure um
well i started reading de luis back in
the mid 70s
when i was in graduate school at the
university of illinois in
champaign-urbana
and um at that time
uh the us was in a weird uh position
because uh uh whereas
structuralism in france for all
practical purposes was
done with by around the late 60s early
70s
and they had moved on to what we've come
to know as as post structuralism
in the us there was a you know
translation gap
most of the people who were been reading
structuralism weren't french departments
reading it in french but to make to make
the breakout of course
these isms have to get into translation
and so the
structuralist stuff and particularly a
lot of roland barth stuff at the time
really rolled out into translation into
in the in the 70s
what was odd about it was that also at
the same time that was rolling out into
translation
or works by the major works of foucault
and and and the crazy thing about that
was that you had the sort of layering of
people sort of trying to absorb
structuralism and
not being in many cases not being fully
aware
of the differences between say what bach
might have been saying in the early 60s
and what
phuket was saying in the early 70s or
darydah was saying in the early 70s and
so that's kind of
i mean that was my problem was trying to
sort all this stuff
out because when i came into graduate
school
uh particularly in champaign-urbana in
the mid-70s
there was all this stuff out there just
you know
floating about this thing we came to
call just generally theory
and so it was it was sort of picking
through all that
um that i came upon i was working on
i was actually more into la calm than i
was in the deluxe
initially and i was reading a lot of
black kong and
and i met a group of guys at
champaign-urbana
including larry grossberg and who you
know went on to become a
rather well-known scholar in cultural
studies and larry was
trying to put together a working group
and we started off talking about
lacan and trying to get you know come to
terms with some of the khan's essays
and then the next semester we had the
new translation of anti-oedipus
on hand and so we worked through that
for a semester
and then we moved on to working on
different essays by from co
and um so it was with that seminar with
that project that i started really
trying to come to terms with the lives
and um
not letting go of it like you know just
not okay the semester's over now i can
move to foucault
i mean i i really stuck with the
um anti-oedipus text trying to figure
out why it was so
uh perplexing annoying fascinating and
and i just uh gradually you know like
kudzu
started looking at delize's other texts
and
and i'd also encountered um logic of
sense
um on a completely different track in
french studies
um somebody i know had done an essay
on um using logic of sense
um pretty much uh in terms of literary
studies which
you know struck me as really odd the
problem with logic of sense was at that
point it wasn't on it was only available
in french
and um i i really had a hard time making
hazard tales
of um how this guy was moving back and
forth between lewis carroll
and um you know logic and sense and
and i really it took me quite a few
years to
to make sense of that but the same was
true of anti-odopus
so that's pretty much how i got involved
and then i just started
you know an academic career and you know
i hate to put it this way but when you
you're in particularly in those days we
had to you kind of had to lay your
cards down and hope for the best in
terms of who where you put your
professional commitments and
there were a lot of different options in
terms of being in french studies
um and i was pretty much involved with
reading narratology and reading gerard
jeannette and a number of
other french writers and more oriented
towards literature
but i stuck with the liz and i just kept
reading to those and and began to write
little bits and pieces about him and uh
um
so you know it just became an important
part of
of what i was doing and thinking so
so this sounds like the time that
academics my
age dream back to as the good old days
all the french
thinkers are coming into english
foucault
lacombe and and so
i mean you can confirm to me whether or
not that rosy
nostalgia is true or not but did you
focus on de las out of
all the stuff that you were reading
because there was a lack of
academic resources available or because
that was your your favorite
encounter it was a combination of the
first couple aspects of the first
um favorite would have been strong
but it was the fact that in a lot of
ways
i i was in some cases i was the only guy
in the room who could read french
and uh so i end up particularly in that
seminar
that i was mentioning with larry
grossberg this is in illinois right
yeah in illinois and uh but also
subsequently i go to
you know uh when i go to a few when i
wasn't going to french conferences i was
going to different other conferences
um you know there would be a lot of
commentary about
these writers but had been read only in
english
so i you know i was sort of a lot of
ways
an annoying presence because uh of
having actually read the things in
french
and not trying to lord that over anybody
but it just
sometimes it sometimes it can make a
difference
and um particularly when you're trying
to work through an english translation
authority passage
and you know if you can have excess
access to the um
french text and see uh where the
what the original is trying to say if
that's clarifying
sometimes it's tough in either language
and you studied in france for a while
too i think i also
read today did i did um an
undergraduate year there and i uh did
i did my master's at the sorbonne and
then
um and i i worked over there uh
running junior year programs completely
you know
uh a part of my academic career was you
know um
just getting these uh and in the late
70s i it was hard to get a job and so i
ran
some junior year programs sort of tied
me over for a year
so i just lived in france and you know
that's an enriching experience all in
itself you know
just being around and soaking up the
culture
yeah this sounds like uh the rosy vision
that every academic
wishes they had a chance well i was
raising you
until you had to see what your paycheck
was
um so that's established i want i want
to give you a quick question that no
doubt has a long answer
but i get this question everywhere i
post
no matter what i post so if we could
just get it out of the way
to start i'd like to ask you this um
where
do i start with deliz and there's
clearly a difference between his
monographic texts and then his work with
qatari
and now the lectures that you're going
to discuss today so
where would you start if you think
you're interested in delaws but you're
not sure yet
well um my the shorter
shortest answer i can give you is um i
like the book that the list came out
with um
it was published i believe in um
19 in the original french was published
in 1991
uh 1990 and then was translated just a
few years later negotiations
is the um translated title pu
paole is the french title um was this
did he oversee its publication because
you're saying it's kind of
collecting a whole bunch of his
different works well it's published by
his
his editor okay min yui and um
so it came out in 1990 so basically what
uh they did was to put together
um some as i'm looking at his
introductory paragraph
here putting together some texts of
discussions um that took place over a
20-year period
and so it's basically a way of getting
a lot of random things that were just
floating around
out there into print while he was still
alive and um the thing the reason i like
this text
um is that it's a whole bunch of
uh deliza's shorter texts but it's
chopped up into five
sections um the first one is on
the first sections on anti-oedipus as
well as a thousand plateaus
um the second one is about second
sections about cinema
different aspects on the cinema project
third is on foucault and those essays
are
those are interviews that dulles gave
and extremely important
um to as sort of eventually
the person then goes to read the book
that lulu's wrote on fuco
um you know they really they really mesh
with each other they
the the interviews uh in enliven a lot
of the texts that
this wrote he has a section number four
is on
it's called philosophy and it's a number
of just general
different takes that he has on
different aspects of his philosophical
undertaking and one of the important
essays in there is called mediators
which is his idea of antioch or people
who
intercede within projects to help people
along
or help something along and that's the
idea of mediating between
one thing and another and it's a really
cool idea that he comes up with but
he throws off all kinds of other
interesting ideas getting getting to
this point in those
and then the final one is politics it's
only got two essays
and one of those is the postscript on
control societies which
has its own status on you can find that
probably anywhere on the internet
um and you know it it's it's sort of the
late deluse
uh where many people would have liked to
lose to go if his health was better if
he'd been
you know been more active somehow um
following his teaching career uh but uh
you know
it's pretty revealing and and it's you
know i think every
everybody knows that one who's reading
to those but in case somebody who wanted
to start
that's a sample of course what that
omits
is that since it starts with a thousand
plateaus
and and and and uh um excuse me with the
anti-utipas and a thousand plateaus
that sort of cuts out all of this
philosophy prior to
um 1970 and uh that's of course the bulk
of a lot of his
interesting early stuff and uh so
it's not that you don't glean and glean
aspects of that in negotiations it's
just that from there
for those uh i i think i'd suggest
possibly uh looking ahead as the book a
short
short interview book that he did um with
claire parnet
dialogues although that that tends to be
more situated within the 70s as well
or uh give myself a plug uh
for the delusions abc's um
the abyss cedar was an eight-hour
interview that he did with claire parnet
he did this about a year after he
retired
from teaching so this would be situated
in 88 and 89
and um it's structured as
uh an a through z type of topic um
uh uh discussion so a is animal b
is drinking which is why and on and on
see as in culture and as he gets warmed
up
uh in the discussions with parnay he
covers a lot of
ground and brings up on many other many
of his topics
that uh that show up in the earlier
works
and um though you don't take any deep
dives
for example you don't take any deep
dives into logic of sense
information or difference in repetition
nonetheless you know aspects of kant k
is in kant is one of the uh letters and
nietzsche pops up uh all the time uh in
his discussion
um so that's another accessible
uh text not text so much as a it's a dvd
that you can just purchase online um
through
anywhere you know you can just uh uh
google it from a to z
is the actual title and uh those are
those are you know a couple different
directions my friend dan
smith uh i asked him you know what he
thought of this question and
you know he said well if you're
interested in nietzsche then read the
niche book
i mean it's as simple as that and uh
you're interested in spinoza
there are several different spino's of
books there's a long spinoza book and a
short spin of the book
i'd say the short spinoza book is is a
great place to start
um but uh you know it just there's
that's the sort of the deep end of the
pool approach too you know if you want
to read
a text we'll just go ahead and read it
and if you can't make any sense
of it well there's lots of commentary
out there to
to give you some direction you know
subsequently there have been a couple
there's
about three different volumes that have
come out of all of his random stuff
um the material that was not published
in
um actually some of the material that
was published in negotiations
is in those three volumes there um
uh desert islands is one of the desert
islands
desert islands right uh two regimes of
madness
and the most recent one is letters and
other texts and
you know that has a lot of interesting
there's a lot of interesting tidbits in
there
and reading to liz's correspondence he
was extraordinarily generous guy
when it came to correspondence i just i
have about four or five letters from him
that he wrote to me while i was a young
professor you know in the 1980s and
you know the guy's generosity of just
taking time out of his day to
to actually you know acknowledge and
give you some information and we tried
to we said we were
corresponding back and forth for several
years trying to set up a meeting
which eventually took place but it took
a he was
you know my schedule his schedule at
some
couple years it didn't work out so too
bad you didn't have zoom eh
yeah well uh you know you got to be able
to plug in
download the app yeah
um so a lot of answers to
where do i start might be the abcs might
be like basically
if you can i haven't i haven't seen that
online yet so maybe i'll i'll look
before i put this up and see if i can
find a link to it
that's the other thing that we were
discussing earlier uh if you
go to youtube um and you know look
look for deluz abc you might be able to
find
um all 26 uh uh
maybe 24 uh sections of it uh
audi the audio visual right there on
youtube
it just depends on who's who's
blocked it or not you know right for
your purposes
yeah this was aired on french television
um
in case it's actually not french it was
a european network
okay so it was published it was you know
broadcast
across europe um with subtitles
uh i guess managed by each of the
national
uh um you know national broadcasting
companies so if you saw it in germany
you'd see it with the german subtitles
and that's you know
italy spain you know so france knows
subtitles and uh
that's better to be in a country with
subtitles
yeah that's public funded broadcasting i
don't see a de la's
netflix special coming out anytime soon
yeah not so much
all right so let's move into the actual
meat
of this interview which is your it
sounds like
an extended uh giant swath of not a
single project but several projects
called the de luz seminars so
i'm not a delis scholar though i have
read the books
most most of them not all i like them
but often i as a reader don't really
feel a compulsion to go beyond an
author's work
into the extra literary material
and this might sound like a mistake from
what we've talked about already
this might sound like a mistake for me
in this case so
what's unknown to many readers including
myself
is that the books many of deliza's books
are
actually the outputs or products of
lectures
and seminars that include uh you know
other people
discussions and you can see this most
tellingly in a thousand plateaus
where you if you know the sources come
from all over the place they're from
different academic departments different
disciplines they're bouncing everywhere
and he didn't do all this work
himself with just guitare it was a
collaborative seminar environment so
and this is a case with the other books
too which i didn't even know until
i checked out charles's work so charles
can you tell us a little bit about how
these
processes went in your understanding and
why
just reading the books alone might leave
some gaps in your knowledge about
the uh the act in thought that's being
performed there
okay well the the way this got started
was again
through a gap um dan smith wanted to
teach a
seminar on foucault and he noticed that
the um uh
he wanted to really get into the uh and
to foucault and to liz on fuco and
he noticed that there are 26 lectures
uh that dulles did on foucault in 1985
86 but he noticed that some of the
transcriptions hadn't even been done
and maybe i should back up and mention
that uh
um from 1979 to
the end of duluz's teaching in 1987 when
he retired
there was a young man named hida nobu
suzuki
who came to france in 1979 to
study literature and somehow he got he
heard about this guy out in
the east of paris at the vance campus
that was
talking about all kinds of crazy stuff
and it turns out that since this guy
liked
kafka he uh wanted to
learn about kafka he learned heard that
this duluz guy had written a book
on kafka with some other crazy guy named
watery
and um so he went out to the lecture and
he quickly noticed that
this room was packed but he decided that
this was kind of
going beyond his french skills so he
took his tape recorder
and um well in the rest of history
hidden obu suzuki turned out to be this
absolutely
strong-willed disciplined young man
tech oriented right great uh recording
machine
apparently and he would get there early
enough so he could sit next to dulu's
year in year out recording every one of
his lectures
and um despite certain gaps which you
know you can imagine
this is the people are only human
nonetheless
uh and this is old technology by the way
so this was cassette recording
there are all these little gaps at about
minute 46 um
at the end of a cassette when cassette
has branching all right
but uh by the way a lot of people who
are listening to this might not even
have ever
held a cassette in their hands so so
yeah so when i'm listening and
transcribing i always waiting for minute
46
so the uh and you say why 46 minutes
because there are 45 minute cassettes
that also had a little bit
longer on the cassette that would go to
about 46 and a half
so uh subsequently the bibliotheque
nacional found this
uh uh um uh project
uh to have been in a part of what they
call the patrimony of france
and so they uh they acquired it from the
young man and they digitized it
and now it's available through the
bibliotech nationale and the french
recordings you can listen to have been
french
directly from the video technology now
on their gallica
software so anyhow jumping ahead dan
uh found that there was gaps and he
wanted to try to fill in some of those
gaps so he got funding through his
university purdue
university to be to fund the
transcriptions
and um and this was the beginning of his
project got several different grants
and then um gradually came through the
neh the international endowment for the
humanities
got a large grant from them and so the
project is to try to make sure we have
the transcriptions that are accurate
and translations that are faithful to
those transcriptions
and making them available publicly
through purdue's site
they delete the the seminar site now
why listen to these at all
um okay going back to our earlier
question where do you start with this if
you're starting with duluz
then these things are probably this
site is probably not of that great
interest
um but one of the
and if you don't speak french if you
can't hear the audio and hear the
interactions
that also there's a certain aspect that
rolling about called the grain of the
voice
you know the grain of the voice really
has a lot uh to do with it but if you're
just hearing some guy speaking french
and it's not making any sense that can
be charming for about 10 seconds and
then you know you want to go on and do
something else
but the translations if you don't speak
french uh
read french the translations show as
much
as we were able to do in print the kind
of atmosphere that reigned in in his
classrooms and
um and that's one of the amazing things
about all this is that
um the classrooms were predominantly
duluth let's be frank this is a
professor who
commanded a lot of respect and he did a
lot of work to prepare for each of his
seminars
but these were in uh public french
university classrooms
seminars and through through many
political
uh upheavals uh on the university
campuses as well as in france more
more generally so uh a lot of the
seminars have people making uh
wild uh interventions and
um watching how delis handles these
things is
just uh astonishing because he
is a a master of diplomacy
so there there are hecklers in french
higher education
lectures oh my god and they're they're
all kinds of
they're all kinds of hecklers i mean
they're coming they're hecklers who come
and just you know
are there to be disruptive uh but
they're also the
hecklers who think they know stuff and
um there's this one guy
throughout year after year of reading
these
um listening to these tapes and reading
this one guy name
his name is george comptes and this
guy is very very knowledgeable man
um but he was basically delizi's um
nemesis as it were um at some point
during the course of any seminar you
could
expect a contest to sort of raise his
hand
and you'd hear this soft voice gradually
begin to build
and then he would just hold forth
15 20 minutes uh just giving these mini
lectures
and the lose just deleuze just came to
accept it in fact
duluz being smart uh he invited the guy
uncertain for the foucault seminar and
this guy knew a lot about foucault
had a different take on foucault than
toulouse so duluth just let him at
different points during the seminar
um hold forth i mean he'd invite him to
he he'd structure it in
to the seminar and um you know
the guy was listening to him he was so
taken with his he was so taken with
every syllable that he said
you could tell he was so invested that
no pearl that came out of his mouth was
uh
to be wasted and um but the lose you
know
got past that personal aspect and really
was able to focus uh in a way that i've
never experienced
able to focus on what the content was to
deal just with the substance and and be
able to respond to that and
uh an amazing thing so i'm not
really i think i've sort of gotten
sidetracked on
the the initial question of why i read
this stuff
um it's to enrich one's understanding
there's a whole personal side to it
um let's take i mean the one that i
uh um can speak to um
you know i did the all 20 of the uh
lectures on the fold the liz's um
final i'm gonna say it wasn't his final
book but
it was the final book honest specific
philosopher
uh live nits and um the the title of the
fold is
it's actually the fold leibniz and the
baroque
and um he did two seminars on leibniz so
this makes
this makes live and it's kind of special
in duluth's land
the uh first four five lectures that he
did in 1980 in the spring of 1980
and sort of and i want to i don't want
to say it's liveness livenet's light
but it was trying to come to terms with
live nets
quickly efficiently but thoroughly in a
five-week
group of lectures but then he came back
to leibniz in
in 1986 and 87
and the reason was there's there are
several reasons why
um one he had already spent a year
working on foucault 8586 and the book on
fuco came out
but prior to that he had spent four full
years
working on cinema and philosophy
and those lectures informed
the two books that he brought out on the
the
the movement image and the time image
two separate books
and um the four years were do this
attempt to try to actually
come to terms with how cinema intersects
with philosophy
in ways that he felt were satisfying and
frankly the craziest thing about these
was that it when you get to the end of
year one
deliz basically says hey you know what
i kind of screwed up here and so
we're going to do a do-over in year two
and so sure enough you come into the
fall
and he goes back over everything he had
done in year one but sort of
twisted in a different direction so
you're working the same material
but like from a different angle and so
it's it's it's
new and then three and years three and
four we're developing uh
the time image more and just extending
but the purpose of him to
going through all this was coming
through a
huge project that was in the back of his
mind
for well over a decade and that was his
idea of doing a book on what is
philosophy
and um every one of these seminars the
the uh livenitz one in 1980
the spinoza one that came in 1981
four years of cinema in
1982 to 1985.
foucault 1986 and the leibniz 97
1987 86-87 were all
part of his much larger um project of
what his philosophy and in fact he says
at the beginning of the
1986 seminar on leibniz he says
i really wanted to do a
seminar on what is philosophy but i just
didn't have the courage to to face this
yet
and so for him this was a massive idea
massive project
but one of the things you discover in
listening to or reading through the
leibniz lectures
if you've looked at the fold if you've
had the chance to try to
work through the book it is
one of the most one of the one of the
tightest
most compressed um it's free i call it
freeze-dried delis
i mean every sentence is is a morsel
that if you're able to pour a little
water onto it
it would expand out into all kinds of
other stuff that you could say
and that's the amazing thing about
following through the 20 lectures
of the liveness seminars is it takes the
material
that you find in on the fold chap
chapter by chapter
and just blows it up let me blow it up
and exploding it but expanding it in
ways that
really bring in you might have a
reference here a tiny footnote in the
fold
which is 10 minutes of of the particular
lecture
and the other aspect is somewhere in the
springtime i couldn't
can i have to look it up but one of the
one of the lectures in the spring is
dedicated to the topic of what is
philosophy
and basically he's lays out kind of the
groundwork
for what will become
most of the opening chapter of what is
philosophy the
the the large structure that he'll be
developing and he hasn't quite worked it
all out yet that takes a few more years
and consulting with guattari but still
he's he's got in mind what he wants to
do so
in this case for example the fold that
really gives you i mean i
was in a group seminar um on the fold
with
some friends uh about 15 years ago
and it never even occurred to me it was
it was
right there at my fingertips um and it
didn't even occur to me
to look at the seminars and and
uh just to see well maybe they might
offer us a little bit
a different perspective yeah they helped
us a whole perspective
you want to know about the whole topic
of point of view he's got a whole
two and a half hour lecture on point of
view um
you want to learn about singularities he
looks at singularities from every angle
including the mathematical uh
angle and he brings in a mathematician
from the department uh at send an e
to discuss uh singularities from the
mathematical perspective and that's one
of the
most interesting lectures i think it's
on january 20th
of 1987. it's just an amazing lecture
from somebody who
who came to the seminar and duluth said
hey you want to talk about this
and well okay why don't you do that
isabelle stengers
comes to talk about um
whitehead and there's a whole section in
the 19
uh uh in the 1987 spring
winter spring part of the seminar where
he talks about leibniz and whitehead
in great detail expanding that out
whitehead makes a sort of a guest
appearance in the fold
the book but you know it's it's a quick
on and a quick off whereas whitehead
gets you know
a lot of development so uh it's
it's pretty interesting uh project and
year after year
you see how student input
um dulu is calling on the resources of
the
people he's come to know in the seminars
over the years
and of course these aren't just students
they're people who just
come take time out of their lives to
um uh be there on tuesday
late tuesday morning and into tuesday
afternoon to
go to duluth's seminars and they might
be uh
you know plumbers they might be um
uh the widows who have this is something
what they do on tuesday morning and they
sit in the front row and
that would that sounds more like lakon
than the liz but
nonetheless you know you have all manner
of people and that was one of the things
that the liz really loved
about his audience was that there's this
whole diversity there
that he could draw upon um as part as a
resource for his work
so he's a little bit of a celebrity um i
just want to rephrase what you said
what you were saying uh what we're
talking about is the book
on leibniz the fold um and
this book i don't understand how anyone
could read this without the internet
because the references are so broad
um he's he's talking about music then
mathematics
than leibniz than than some other
philosopher and i don't know how
anyone like being alive now
i think makes this possible but i
couldn't i had to read this book in
front of the computer
and basically google every reference
that he's bringing up because it's
constant and it's not organized
but you telling this story about okay
there's a mathematics professor coming
in or
there's an art person coming in or i
don't know a music a musicologist coming
in
this kind of gives sense to why the book
is written like that because as a book
it's a nightmare
but if you're seeing this as the tip of
the iceberg of a whole
bunch of work a whole bunch of lectures
a whole bunch of
guests all coming in then it kind of
makes this book
make a lot more sense and you're saying
that this isn't just the leibniz book
that does this which is under
120 pages or so maybe it's about that
130 yeah
um yeah and then all of these books are
like that is what you're saying so this
seems like a
kind of a necessary resource unless you
have google maybe
i think of livens as the extreme um in
that regard
okay really he was really i'm gonna make
this
as terse as i possibly can
and i don't know why i don't think he
really had a page length uh
uh limitation in in what he was writing
but um the thing that's the the your
comment really makes me think
of that if you look also another reason
for looking at the
if you're entered into this book the
fold and you think oh my god what a
hodgepodge
um then you should look at the way he
lays out his course
because his course is very very of
course
follows the structure of the book right
um but
the way he lays out the course it's very
logical
why he would have this particular
unfolding uh so to speak
uh in the way that he does it and um
and he organizes the course in the
course in um
two segments one leibniz and philosophy
which corresponds corruptly to chapters
one two and three
and then he deals with what he calls
liveness and freedom
and that pretty much deals with what
would correspond to the
rest of the book after chapter maybe
three or four
um but there he's dealing with the
concept of freedom in a broad sense
within leibniz and you know that was
something that struck me as very very
odd
when i was starting when i was working
on the translations because when
i had already read the fold and i
thought it was some freedom
what does that have to do with anything
and i realized oh
duh you missed it uh when you're reading
through this the first two or three two
or three times
it's such an important concept but it's
just sort of a stealth concept
um that's that's that's working its way
through
uh all these other myriad concepts
and theoreticians as you mentioned uh
that are brought in to
sort of exemplify different aspects of
of the fold i mean the whole
architectural aspect of the fold
early on is something that can be
extraordinarily off-putting if you've
never considered baroque architecture or
you know baroque sculpture or anything
and
that itself you know in the book it's
really
really tight he develops that in
really interesting detail in the opening
lectures of that seminar
yeah so i mean i thought he was being
deliberately
obscurant so it it's really helpful that
i have you to tell me that this is what
was happening because it makes it seem
like
okay okay it was a very a very tight
condensation of a
whole lot of work from a whole lot of
people and we could say that about
deliza's general philosophical project
as well
sure if the books are highly abridged
versions of the lectures
um i'll ask for i'll ask for some links
but um
what are you doing with your with the
project with dan smith
putting this all um online is it gonna
be like
open access is it going to be a book
eventually or
a series of books what do you what do
you have planned for that no
no books it won't be any books um
that's a that's sort of a stipulation
by the deleuze family um they won't
they don't want and he didn't want any
of this stuff in print
but the opposite side of the coin is
it's complete open access
free to anybody who can link on to it so
um and a lot of it's already available
um
you know it's at the the website is for
those of you who have a pencil ready
um i'll put it in the link so they can
click on it okay so it's uh
duluz dot
and um and that takes you to the front
page and then you just work your way
from there
um but one of the the biggest discovery
for me
uh in this project i got involved with
this
actually about 20 years ago well before
uh dan uh had come up with this idea
because there's a guy
as a musician named richard pinos who
had
uh who who went to duluth's lectures
and recorded a whole lot of them he was
he was
less um uh
faithful if you will to the to
attendance than
suzuki but nonetheless he attended a lot
of them and he had his own recordings
and so he
transcribed his recordings and put a lot
of them
up onto his own website as well as he
had a
part of his website for his music and a
part of his website for de luz
and um i got it uh roped into
starting to do translations of those
transcriptions the stuff that he had on
his website
so that he could get a lot of the
english translations and
also other languages onto his website
and um one of the things that i didn't
realize
at the time and it's only been recently
that i've really
become fully aware of this is just how
much he edited out
in putting his transcripts up from the
actual
uh recordings that he made himself and
that suzuki made um
so what i've had to do
i really become uh distrustful
of anything that i haven't heard myself
and so i've just gone started to go
through
every single uh recording that i work on
and i have gotten a really nice little
process worked out where
i'll even if i have a transcript in hand
um i'll listen to the recording with uh
i'll read the transcript first by itself
and make my own edits on what i'm
reading there if i see things that need
to be cleaned
and then we'll go listen to it and then
start filling in
gaps because there inevitably are gaps
some shorter and some longer depending
on who's done the transcribing
and it's only then do i go on to do the
uh translations and try to make the
translations actually be based on um
you know what what actually occurred and
a lot of times you know
some of the things i'm talking about as
gaps these are not
significant in the sense that oh my god
staval really captured that one word
that makes everything different you know
right not at all i mean it's
a lot of times even the hesitations de
lewis has
um that might get edited out by somebody
who says oh we don't want to hear the
liz
going on and off right sometimes the
hesitations are very very significant
because
he's thinking and working out the
concepts
as he's delivering them to the students
and he's got a
lesson plan he's got a little he's got a
little piece of paper in front of him or
several little pieces of paper
but he doesn't write out his lectures he
didn't write out his lectures
he he just riffed off of his notes
and he would bring texts into class of
course that he would read from so he
would have a reference book and then
he'd open up the book
and he'd carefully read and comment on
something and so that would take a while
but so he he was really prepared but a
lot of the times it was
it was him creating a lot of this stuff
with the students generated by their
interest
and a lot of times by their questions
because certain questions
would send him off in different
directions and he would answer
questions really thoroughly or he would
just say the student
you know what that's a great question uh
and he he what he would want to say was
don't send me down that rabbit hole
yeah because that would be for him and
he would just circle back around to it
and try to come back to it if not in the
class uh
in another uh session and but he really
was a attentive to that
this brings me to a little bit of a more
personal question maybe but it's
something that i can
only ask a few people in the world
including yourself so
you've listened to uh probably hours and
hours and hours of these lectures
met with deliz after reading
reading him as a grad student compared
to now
having listened to his voice for so long
um
what what insight do you have that you
wouldn't have had from reading the books
about de luz the man
or deliz the teacher or maybe vendela's
plus gatari his relationships and
interactions and things like that
oh well i know that's an impossible
thing to put into
that's right what i'm trying to do is
put myself back
in my the frame the framework
let's go back to the 1970s at rosy time
the problem with reading all of that
stuff
at the time was that i i
didn't have the um
full enough of a grasp of the historical
and sociocultural
um stakes that were involved
in say anti-oedipus like i didn't
understand
why um staking out
a position uh against uh
for freud and psychoanalysis was such a
big deal
why coming up with an alternate uh
reading
of marx not against marx but a read
alternate reading of marx
within a sociocultural context why that
was such a big deal
um and even to stake out a position
not against luckcom but you know
still this was not uh full-on
jacques lacombe why that was such a big
deal
in the night in in 1972 when antiodicus
came out
and i came to figure that out and i
realized that you know
these guys had their own political
commitments but also intellectual
commitments
and these intellectual commitments were
things that then subsequently played out
over the years and affected their lives
so
what i didn't understand then was how
post structuralism as well
um how the different kinds of uh what
we've sort of
categorized you know within bookshelves
and
in conferences and so forth within
certain categories
how this was alive within the culture
how it became how it developed
through the uh um interplay
between intellectuals uh in france in
the 1960s
and 1970s and you know and deliz in a
lot of ways
um was unusual and then he stayed with
his teaching career all the way
to to you know completing a full career
and then retired it uh in 1987
and um you know had had done pretty much
what he was able to do physically having
always been a a little bit in ill health
for various reasons um but uh
uh i you know what i've what i've
gotten subsequently out of uh listening
to
these recordings is just uh you know
the human side of this guy um
it was it's it's just fascinating to
hear how he deals with
the stuff that all teachers have to deal
with
you know classroom time management um
uh space issues uh bureaucratic issues
trying to get students to complete
forms um
these don't you know these don't occupy
huge amounts of time
uh in these recordings i i have to
confess but
this precisely that you'd hear like this
right at the end of one of the things i
was just working on he he points out at
the beginning of the class that
you know there are these little yellow
forms that you have to have
um and i have to have liz has to have
uh so that i can go on and teach this
next part of the semester so be sure to
fill those out
so he gets through the whole lecture two
hours later he's
he's wrapping things up and he goes oh
yeah and and
the little yellow forms the little
yellow forms
here you got this uh you know this
renowned scholar this this philosopher
all of a sudden
could you and then you hear him right
next to the microphone he's whispering
he said oh god
i wish i didn't have to chase after them
you know
and it's so funny dude to hear you know
that you think oh oh my god he
he's he's dealing with the same kind of
stuff that were
as teachers that were all dealing with
um
and dealing and that was one of the
reasons why he and well the fact he
decided to retire when he
when he did he mentions this in the
obvious idea
he just basically got worn down by uh
the bureaucracy and uh and he just felt
that the demands
on his time and the demands on teachers
in general had come to a point where
he had to part ways it was just uh it
was
it was just it was not getting the
payoff and he also felt physically
that he wasn't able to give what he felt
was needed uh in his physical
performances because that's the other
thing
you hear to what extent these are
performances
i mean he's just uh when he's on he's
really on
and he's just investing um
all kinds of energy into these two hour
sessions
and just i mean just keeping track of
where he's going
in this flow of ideas is is amazing
enough but then to
sort of invest this kind of he creates
different personalities
um as he's presenting stuff he'll mimic
stuff he'll
take on the personality of leibniz and
they'll sort of
you know channel inner liveness or he'll
throw in a little inner niche
and and then and you're when you're
transcribing this trying to figure out
who's speaking here that's one of the
trickiest things is to just try to
you know sort those things out so that
the reader will be able to
understand that okay this is not the
lewis speaking in his own voice this is
him presenting leibniz in a particular
way just to take one example
um and he said i i this is just a
personal question he's
there's a lot of uh notes in his writing
where he's
um borderline he's ironic or sardonic
or a little subversive does any of that
trickiness come out in these lectures or
that
feeling of him uh being a gadfly
uh well i yeah i don't i think
that the very nature of judging someone
to be a gadfly is that you're kind of
a fly on the wall just judging the guy i
don't i don't
he he he's very very genuine you know
he's not trying
that's one of the things that um he's
very forthright about he's really not
trying to mess with anybody's minds he's
really not trying to play any games
he'll speak his mind uh pretty
forthrightly but on the other hand
he is really one of the kindest
individuals i mean the way he deals with
the students
even the students particularly the
students who are you can tell the most
endangered
there's this one student who
uh in the cinema seminars i i i was
listening to this recently she she has a
crush on deliz
and she basically stands up in class and
she wants to profess
she has the the pretext is to give a
presentation on a particular topic that
they're discussing but she basically
just confesses
in front of the whole class that she
just wants to get to know him and hang
out with him
and apparently she called him the
weekend before at home and
had been talking to him so he kind of
knew this was coming
that there was this issue but the way he
dealt with her was just
so kind um
honest um you know like in front of all
the students you know this really isn't
going anywhere
but uh on the other hand he asked her to
come back make sure that she came back
the following week
to discuss in the class the topic that
she wanted to talk about
not not her her crush on the liz
but the literary topic and so he does
she does come back
unfortunately uh more fortunately
perhaps i don't know
uh that that presentation was never
recorded
it's i think both suzuki and um
cut off the recording at that point and
the recording starts up after her
presentation
but this did ask her at the beginning of
class the next time to
to speak and uh you know it's just it
but
but that's an extreme all the time he's
very very
uh conscious of being um you know
working with the students and being
careful with the students and and trying
to help them and
and making every effort in his lectures
you just hear it
in the language he uses um it
particularly his self reproaches when he
thinks he's gone too fast
uh when he thinks he hasn't developed
something sufficiently he'll go back
over something
in fact you know some of the judgments
that are made or his harshest ones are
him on himself uh coming back and going
back over something he felt he screwed
up so
it's uh it's it's i don't know i don't
see
any of th what you you described there
in
in his actual personality just somebody
who had that generosity
and the idea that he actually took time
out back in 1985
to to invite me over to his apartment to
have a drink with this
young american who you know had all
these questions
for him and he just said you know
basically was you know
chill out have a drink let's just talk
and uh no i'm not giving you an
interview and uh
and but you know it's it's nice to meet
new people and it was
i understand now much better than i did
then you know
uh where where that was coming from
what kind of drink did he offer you i
think i had
i think i chose a whiskey i mean i i had
a whole had a whole choice um
but i think i chose the whiskey very
nice i wonder if the uh
university administration or the
department heads had the same impression
of
of him as his students ah yes well
he got along with you know his his uh
media supervisors right right i mean
what is philosophy he goes off on the
bureaucratization and marketing
dimensions of
of the university anyway i have one more
question for you
because surely going through this stuff
raking
breaking the muck in the detail that
you've done offers uh
a lot of surprises so i just wanted to
know if there's a surprise or moment or
instance that sticks out to you
in uh going through all this when your
mind was just blown for a second and
it had it forced you to reconsider your
previous positions
ah well mind-blowing yeah
uh this would be the time we would we
would take a break and i could go
i could think of i mean i've had my mind
blown
but not for the reasons that you know
you're just suggesting that i just had
to sort of rethink everything
um i guess um
the real um wake up for me
uh concerned the cinema books because
for me the cinema books
for all practical purposes were
impenetrable
uninteresting and impenetrable until i
started working on
um this project and then i came to
understand
more clearly where he was coming from
what it
um and then and and this was a long
haul for him yeah but he really had a
commitment to this
he really had a commitment to trying to
work through the concepts
of cinema work through the concepts of
bergson
because bergson is the jumping off point
for the cinema books
and i just hadn't i mean i knew that but
i hadn't fully appreciated that
and then charles sanders purse and the
persian
structures terminology that he brings to
this project that was always the most
off-putting
to me why bother in coming up with this
sort of
weird terminology for these different uh
effects of cinema
i'm not really sure yet i've i've fully
answered
that question for myself with any
satisfaction
but i can see how in in the lectures
these
uh are important turning points for just
trying to conceptualize um the different
aspects of the movement image and then
shift to the time image
i'm not sure still and that was another
misgiving i always had about the cinema
books i'm not sure
that that double structure really works
um doesn't satisfy me frankly very much
in thinking about cinema but then again
um you know i think about cinema
and in a very very lazy sort of way
and i certainly admit that
[Music]
isn't lazy when it comes to to thinking
through cinema and that's
these books are proof to that all right
wow okay great we are about at time here
so uh we have a closing question but i'd
like to first uh
thank you charles charles deval for
hopping on with us today and for keeping
us youngins
in check we cannot we gotta we gotta
revise our
our you know what we think are radical
opinions every so
once in a while so um please look at the
links in the description if your
appetite
has been wedded i'm going to go back
through this when i edit and
try to find all the things that have
been referenced by by charles here but
most especially
is the seminar project out of purdue
co-project with daniel w smith and it
sounds like a lot of other people so
i'll link
i'll find as many links to that as i can
and it feels like we've barely scratched
the surface here even after
over an hour so um i think people are
getting a little more excited about
delis for whatever reason and you as
someone who's
almost dedicated your your life to to
projects like this
um would you say it's a it's a worthy
endeavor even if you don't do it
specifically
in in school is there enough delus to
keep you going for
you know another lifetime oh yeah oh
goodness grief yes well you know i mean
this is this is my retirement now so
uh i'm enjoying it every day i get up
and i do
do a little duluth so i think there's
there's a lot to be said about that a
little to losing a little yoga you know
take you a long way
yeah most of the most of the boomers are
heading down to florida at this point so
good on you um there you have it this is
plastic pills
for the plastic pills podcast we have an
overdose episode with charles deval
and you know based on your feedback we
might have to have
charles back if he has if he has the
time so thanks so much charles
pleasure thank you very much and uh yeah
i'll stop recording
[Music]
you